What do we do then when we feel trapped in our faith starts to give way to fear?
What do we do in that situation? Well, we can read about what the Israelites did,
verses 10 to 12 in chapter 14. They cry out in fear to God. They look over at Moses, and they
start to lash out at him and to blame him. You hear them say things like, did you bring us
out here because there weren't enough graves in Egypt? So you can hear the snark in how they say this.
They even look back and they say they would have been better to remain a slave in Egypt than to die
out here. That's relatable, because I know that there are times when my faith
starts to give way to fear. I know there have been days when I've looked backwards with regret.
I know there have been times when I looked for other people to blame and have spoken harshly to them
or about them. And so I need to hear what Moses says to the people of Israel, and I'm sure we all do.
And that's in chapter 14, verse 13, when he says, fear not, stand firm and see the salvation of the Lord.
So what are we to do? We're to fear not, stand firm and see the Lord's salvation. So how can we stand firm
then when our faith is starting to give way to fear? Well, it's certainly not found in looking to
ourselves, because as we read and sung earlier from Psalm 121, our help comes from the Lord.
So I want us to see two major truths about the Lord from the Red Sea Crossing
that will hopefully help us to stand firm when we are in situations like this.
And the first truth is this, the Lord guides his people. As we're looking to the Lord, we're looking
to the one who guides his people. We can stand firm wherever we are, because we can know that
the Lord is the one who brought us there. So when Pharaoh let the people go, it wasn't for
them to then figure out how to get to the promised land. The Lord was going to lead them there.
And here we see that he leads them in some unusual ways. Let me just give you three unusual
things that we see here. One is he leads them along an unusual route or route. I'm not sure
how which one's the right one to say. He leads them in a weird way. So if you're to go to
to Google Maps, say and type in Canaan if you were in Egypt, it would have taken you on a far more
direct route. You certainly would not have come by the Red Sea. In fact, some Bibles have a map in
the back. So if that's one of yours, I found it helpful this past week to just flick back
to that map and have a look because you can see there was a route that would have taken you
right along the Mediterranean would have been far quicker. And instead they start
heading southward and they even headed in the direction of where the sea was, which was
certainly going to get in their way if they're going to head eastward to the promised land.
Now I know some of us are you know, happy go lucky sorts of people just go, I'm just along for the
ride sort of folks. But I'm sure there are also people here among us who would have been saying,
hang on a second, this is not the most direct route. I've thought about this. You're heading
the wrong way. But the fact is God still knows what he is doing by leading them in that
direction as opposed to the other. More specifically, he knows that they were not ready to head down
that other more direct route. Because he knows that route would have taken them right to the land
of the Philistines, we're told. Now we know that they were armed, but that doesn't mean that
they were prepared for this battle with the Philistines because they first needed to be
formed in the wilderness. So they were equipped, but they were not formed yet.
So he leads them in a different way. The same thing is true with us.
There are times, yes, when life feels like we've accidentally taken the wrong way,
the long way around, perhaps. But in those moments, we can still know this,
God isn't lost. And he is leading us. And he is shaping us on this journey. And in
leading us the long way around, he may very well be mercifully taking us or keeping us away
from things that we're not yet ready to face. I love this proverb, Proverbs 16, 9,
says, the heart of a man plans his ways, but the Lord establishes his steps. So it's good and right
to be thinking ahead and to be thinking about the future, planning our ways. What we do so,
knowing that at the end of the day, it's the Lord who establishes our steps. And sometimes
those steps are the long way around, but the Lord is guiding. So he guides them on this
unusual route, but also he guides them with an unusual item in tow. They've got something packed
that's a bit strange. I remember watching a TV show that was airport security. And it was all
about the kind of weird things that people bring through security. And you've got the,
obviously, the kind of ordinary contraband, but you'd also have the occasional exotic
animal that somebody was trying to sneak through and that sort of thing. Well, here we've
got this unusual item that they're taking with them in verse 19. It's Joseph's bones.
By the way, that's chapter three in verse 19. So why are they taking the bones of Joseph with them?
Well, this is giving us kind of two bookends of Israel's time in Egypt, because their time in
Egypt began when Joseph arrived in Egypt. And then the other bookend is now the Exodus.
So Joseph is one of these first Israelites who was taken to Egypt. And then right before he
died in Genesis 30, he got the people of Israel to confess that God was going to visit them and
bring them out, but to also confess that they were going to carry his bones out of there
when they left. So this is the fulfillment of a promise that was made long ago.
And when you think about the story of Joseph, which I would encourage you to read there at
the end of Genesis, we also see that as they're carrying these bones, they have a reminder
of God's providential care for his people that he always keeps his promises, because Joseph went
through all kinds of hardships the long way around, if you will. But here was Joseph's perspective
in the end, Genesis chapter 15, verse 20. He said, you meant it for evil against me, the people
that sought to do him harm. But he said, but God meant it for good. So God brought about
his good plans in and through Joseph's life in ways that Joseph would have never mapped out for
himself. And yet it was done in such a way that he could in the end rejoice, saying that God led me
all the way. So as we look at Joseph's bones here, let it be a reminder to us that even on the
darkest days, God's providence is still directing our steps. And his promises are there to light
each step of the way. And even when it's not the path we would have chosen, we can know that God is
still ordering our steps according to his perfect wisdom. So they're going this unusual way with
this unusual piece of luggage. And then you got this unusual, you might say, manifestation.
So you got a pillar of clouds that appears by day and then is a pillar of fire by night.
And these were a manifestation of the presence of the Lord with them. This is God making his presence
known just like he made his presence known to Moses at the burning bush. He's now making his
presence known to his people here. And this is not the only time he appears in this specific way. I
mean, when you look forward then in the book of Exodus, when we get to chapter 19 and they
reach Sinai, we read that God descends in fire on Mount Sinai and it's covered in smoke
as well. You get to Exodus 40, you've got the cloud covering the tabernacle and it is filled with the
brightness of God's glory. But all of this is showing that God is present with his people. So they have
no reason to fear. Later on in Scripture we see that this very account is used to show that
God is present with his people in every generation just as he was with his people on that day
at the Red Sea. So he was going to be with his people forever. Isaiah 43 verses 1 and 2.
Listen to these words. God says, fear not, for I have redeemed you. I have called you by name.
You are mine. When you pass through the waters, that's that throwback to the Red Sea. When you
pass through the waters, I will be with you. And this same God who said that has made his
presence known to us in the person of his Son. And in the Gospels we can see so many throwbacks
to Exodus and even the Red Sea. But one of them is Jesus takes his three disciples or three of his
disciples up a mountain. And when he's on that mountain, the mountain of transfiguration,
it's covered in a cloud and Jesus has transfigured before them and begins to shine almost like
fire. So this same Jesus promised that he would be with his people always, even to the end of the age.
And he is present with us now by his spirit. So every moment that we face, even the hard ones,
we can be assured that we are not facing them alone because he never departs by day or by
night. He has promised Hebrews 13.5 that he will never leave us or forsake us. And in Hebrews 13,
it's presented in a way that says, this is how we can be content in the situation that we're in
because he has said, I will never leave you nor forsake you. So the Lord guides his people.
So he's present with us, guiding us, ordering our steps in his good way.
But also we see something else here. We see that the Lord also fights for his people.
In chapter 14 and verse 14, the people are given this amazing reassurance. It says,
the Lord will fight for you. You have only to be silent. In the end, it's the Egyptians who
were saying, let us flee from before Israel for the Lord fights for them. You see that in verse 25.
And the Lord who fought for them on that day fights for us today. Let's see a couple of things. One is,
let's look at who he fights, who the Lord fights. Our attention is drawn back to Pharaoh here because
after Israel, Flood Pharaoh changed his mind about letting them go. You see that in verse 5. And so he
gathers together his armies and his arsenal to go and to hunt them down. And he does this in a way
that is putting, you might say, the glory of Egypt on full display. It's a bit like a modern dictator,
you know, having a military parade, kind of putting all of the glory and might of the country
on display. So it's a major flex here that Pharaoh puts forward in verses 6 and 7.
So Pharaoh gets his chariot ready. And we're told he's got 600 other choice chariots. So these are
the best in Egypt that he gets. But that's not even enough. He then takes all the chariots of
Egypt. And so he and the officers and all the strength of Egypt are following after the people.
And by the way, the chariots are going to be spoken of throughout chapter 14 and chapter 15
throughout chapter 14 and chapter 15 and the rest of scripture as well.
And these chariots are put forward later in scripture as a picture of human strength and
worldly resources. So Pharaoh has all of these at his disposal. So he is standing highly exalted,
you might say, above it all. If you don't mind, you could say he was at the top of the pyramid.
All right, so you've got Pharaoh kind of at the top right here with all this strength and resources
at his disposal. And so when he's coming towards God's people, the Israelites were told in verse 10
that the Israelites look up and see them coming. And the language there seems to be a deliberate
contrast with what it then says about the Lord in verse 24. Because the Israelites look up
seeing the Egyptians coming. But then what says the Lord saw them, he looked down to see them.
He's not intimidated. You see, although the enemy appears highly exalted and strong,
it is the Lord who is far more powerful. And he's the one who is truly highly exalted above all.
Their power is nothing compared to him. And he will not share his glory with another.
Isaiah 42, verse 8. So you get verses 4 and 18 where it makes it clear that God is acting on that day
at the Red Sea for the glory of his name. That's what's that's the major thing that's motivating
the Lord here, the glory of his name. He is going to be glorified by bringing down this king and
this kingdom who are exalting themselves against him by attacking his people. So you see in
verse 18, let's just read it. The Egyptians shall know that I am the Lord when I have gotten glory
over Pharaoh, his chariots and his horsemen. You then see this repeated in Isaiah 63, 12. It says,
the Lord divided the waters before them, making for himself an everlasting name. It's the glory
of his name being displayed here. Here it's put before us in vivid detail that God opposes the proud.
Those who exalt themselves against him and his people will eventually be brought low.
And there are people today who exalt themselves against the Lord, certainly,
and even against his people as well. This past week, I had the wonderful privilege of having
dinner with a pastor from a country in Central Asia who was passing through.
And he was full of joy, but the country that he is serving in is not an easy place in the world
to be. It's a place where it is illegal to be a missionary and there are still folks who are
serving there in creative ways, but it's not an easy place to serve as a missionary.
But then the conversation, and it's a country I'm familiar with, it became clear once again that
the worst a missionary really has to face in that country is that they might be taken to the airport
and deported never to return again. But he's a, the guy I was talking to is a local church leader.
And so when, if everybody else is kicked out, all the foreign missionaries are kicked out of
the country, he's still there. And there are times, there have been multiple times,
one time recently, when he's been taken away from his home and he has been interrogated because of
his faith and intimidated as well, threatened. But as I was speaking to him, the joy of the Lord
was overflowing. He wasn't scared. He knew that he belonged to the Lord and he knew that the
Lord, the Lord's work could not be stopped either in his life or in the country. And as
he spoke about the Lord's work there, he spoke with great hope about what is coming in the days ahead.
The fact is the Lord will be exalted in all the earth. No amount of opposition will stop him. He
will be exalted above all evil powers. He will be glorified by rescuing his people from every
tribe, tongue, and nation. He is glorified by saving people from their enslavement to sin,
and he will be glorified eventually by bringing about the final demise of the captor, the evil one.
Satan. So what do we do? When we hear the Lord fight for us, well let's lift our eyes to the Lord
rather than the opposition. So when we see this horrible thing heading our way, let's lift our
eyes beyond this great thing that is intimidating us to the Lord who is exalted above all of it.
Because he is our hope. Yes, evil is real, and there are powers that want us to be enslaved to
sin, but they will not ultimately prevail. The Lord prevails. He fights for us, and he has defeated
sin and death, and he will finish the work that he begins in our lives just like he promised.
He is our hope. He is our strength. Let's this be a reminder to us as well. Our trust is not to
be in human strength or material resources to accomplish the Lord's work. He is the one who does it.
So we read this later on in Scripture, Psalm 20, verse 7. Some trust in chariots and some in horses,
but we trust in the name of the Lord our God. Does the Lord use earthly things? Absolutely.
He's the maker of all of it, or Psalm 24 says, the earth is the Lord in all the fullness thereof,
but our trust isn't rooted in earthly things, but in the Lord Himself, the maker of heaven and earth.
So this is who the Lord fights. Let's also see how the Lord fights as well.
Now there are times, and we'll see this later in Exodus, when he enables his people to fight,
but that's not the case here at the Red Sea. Here he fights the battle for them,
but notice how he fights two things. One is he fights by dividing, and then secondly,
he fights by defeating. So let's look at that. He divides, so they are at the Red Sea. Now in
our modern world, we've forgotten just how much bodies of water actually separate places and
people in the world. Now if we drive up to a major river, we just keep driving until we get to the
bridge, because we know there's eventually going to be a bridge where we can cross to the other side.
Well, that wasn't always the case in the ancient world, and it would be mind-boggling to people
all those years ago to think that we're actually crossing oceans. There's thousands of people
crossing oceans every day of the week. The bodies of water separate. They divide, and you
see them playing that role in Scripture in various places, but they certainly divide peoples and nations,
and the Red Sea here is put before us as a major dividing line, because a new life is on the
other side for the Lord's people. But even before the Israelites cross that river, and we'll return
to it, or the sea rather, we see that God makes a distinction between them and the Egyptian
army. There's another dividing line he makes. We see in chapter 14, verses 19 and 20, that the cloud
that was going before them now comes behind them, and it's there between them and the Egyptian army.
So God's very presence is the barrier standing between his people and their enemy. So in order
to get to them, they're going to have to go through the Lord himself, because he's divided
them out. And this division then continues on in a way that nobody there on that day saw coming.
Moses then stretches out his hand across the sea, and we read that the Lord
drove the sea back by a strong east wind all night until the waters were divided.
And they had dry land coming right down the middle. It's like the third day of creation
there in Genesis one, when God separates the waters and makes dry lands to appear.
And so this new life is now there ahead of God's people.
And he's brought about the dry land to get them there. So in this division of the waters,
God makes a way of salvation. If they move forward by faith, they will arrive safely on the
other shore. So the Red Sea here, let's say it a different way. The Red Sea is a place of division
because it's a place of both salvation, but it's also a place of judgment. That's the dividing
line here. Because in this division, the Lord then defeats the enemy. Because after the Israelites
pass through and they're on the other side, the Egyptian army is then allowed to pursue them,
and they make their way into the sea on that land. But as they go along in their strong chariots,
their wheels began to clog and to come loose. The impressive strength that they relied upon
began to fail them. And then they eventually recognize they can't rely on the strength
anymore because the Lord is fighting for his people, they say. And so they decide to flee.
But then it is too late. The walls of water come crashing down on them in judgment. So they are
judged. And God's people are saved. God's people were told, you will see the salvation of the Lord
and they did. So there's this dividing line of judgment and salvation here at the Red Sea.
So when we think about salvation that we see here, the word for salvation is Yeshua. When you come to
the New Testament, this is the very name of who? Of Jesus. This is pointing us to Jesus here,
because it's in Jesus now that we see the Lord's salvation. We see this greater exodus that he
brings about through Jesus. And in Scripture we go on to see that yes, the sea is literally a place
of death and judgment. We see that here. But then later on in Scripture we see that it's symbolically
used to speak of death and judgment as well. So Revelation chapter 20 verse 13, it speaks about
the sea giving up its dead. And then one of the first things we read about in terms of the
New Creation in Revelation 21 is that there is no more sea. So why is it telling us there's no more
sea in the New Creation? It's not talking about bodies of water there. It's speaking about not the
absence of these bodies of water, but the absence of death and judgment that's gone now, the
separation from God is gone for those who dwell in the New Creation. How can that be the case?
How can that be the case? Death is no more in this way. It's because of the salvation that God
accomplished through Jesus. The fact is we were God's enemies, but the waters of judgments
that we deserved fell on Jesus instead of us. The Lord fights for us, yes, but on the cross
we see that the Lord fought for us by laying down his life for us and dying in our place.
Jesus is the way of salvation. So let's imagine ourselves standing there at the Red Sea now,
but as we're looking back, we're looking back on a life where we were enslaved by sin. And our
sin accuses us as we're looking back. And as we turn this way and look forward, we look at
death. We see, well, if sin is pursuing me, well, death is what I deserve. I deserve judgment.
So how do I respond when I'm trapped in that situation thinking about my sin and thinking
about the judgment that I deserve when I think about death? How do we respond? Here's the response.
Look to Jesus by faith. See the salvation that the Lord has provided in him. You see,
there is nothing for us to do when it comes to salvation. He fought the battle for us. All that
is there for us to do is to stand still and to see the salvation of the Lord. In Jesus, we see the
way that God has opened for us. And so we simply step forward in faith believing that Jesus has
defeated our sin, believing that he has defeated death through his death and believing that he is
leading us into the life that he has promised. We look to him by faith. And Scripture teaches that
when we look to Jesus by faith, we are united to him in his death and resurrection. And this is
portrayed in our baptism as well. So Romans chapter six goes on to speak about us being
baptized into Jesus's death and then raised to newness of life. So we're united to Jesus in his death.
It's like being immersed in those waters where we die to ourselves and we're raised again to newness
of life because Jesus rose again from the dead. And so when we come to that final river as it were,
we can face it with confidence in Christ knowing that he will safely bring us or bring us safely to
the other shore. I love how John Bunyan portrayed this in Pilgrim's Progress, specifically with
Mr. Valiant for Truth, because he comes and he enters the river. And as he enters the river,
he says, death where is thy sting? And it says, in going deeper, he added, grave where is thy
victory? So he crossed over and the trumpet sounded for him on the other side. So how do we respond?
Looking to Jesus by faith. And then one last thing, we respond by living by faith.
So the fact is if we can trust Jesus in death, we can trust him in life.
To go back to where we started, we can trust him in times of uncertainty. So rather than
ruminating on past decisions or looking for someone to blame, this is surely a call for us
to silently look to Jesus knowing that we can trust in him, our life now and what we're facing in this
moment is secure in him. So let me ask this question, where is your gaze this morning?
If you feel trapped, where are you looking? Is it on the greatness of the issue?
Looking up to that, or are your eyes on the greatness of your Savior who loved you enough
to die for you? So if you're feeling stuck this morning, maybe in a pattern of sin or a hard
moment in life, look to him because he is present with you, guiding your steps,
providentially leading you forward. And he is the one who fights for you.
So in the words of the Apostle Paul, be strong in the Lord and in the power of his might. May we
move forward together knowing that the way has been opened up for us through Christ. So let's pray.
God, we thank you that you were not only present with your people then all those years ago at the Red Sea,
but you the same God are present with us now. Lord, your spirit guides us. And Lord, I pray that right
now the guiding hand of your spirit leading us to Jesus. But I pray that you would lift our eyes to
him. Lord, that you would show us that we can trust you because of what he has done for us.
Lord, we thank you that he died for us and rose again. Lord, I pray that you would lift our
eyes away from ourselves, away from our circumstances to our mighty and loving Savior who died for us.
So Lord, as we come to your table now, Lord, I pray that we would do so from a place where we are
thinking upon what you have done for us. Lord, I pray that you'd help us to come forward
by faith. Lord, as the people walk through those waters coming forward into the life you've given them.
Lord, as we come forward to receive the bread and the wine, I pray that we would come forward
by faith in Christ knowing what he endured for us. And Lord, as we receive this and we move forward
into the week ahead, Lord, I pray that you would keep our eyes fixed upon you. I pray all
this in Jesus' name. Amen.